never before and never since has a
single philosopher had such a
tremendous impact as karl marx's
great vision of the propertyless
society found a hearing worldwide
revolutionary parties governments and
entire states referred to him and
his philosophy the so-called marx is
must spread all around
around the globe in countries as different as russia, china, vietnam, cuba,
nicaragua
and mozambique, but also in many
other countries, revolutions broke out
until almost a third of the entire
human population embraced communism about
100 years after his death, the
communist world he had brought into being went
again  down and after the fall of the
iron curtain, many marx
thought he was wrong and that
capitalism was ultimately the only
promising economic system.
people hoped to reconcile democracy, a market economy
and the fair distribution of
wealth,
but this optimism did not
last long
the global economic and
financial crises have deeply shaken belief in the
market economy it
is now becoming increasingly clear
that capitalism unfortunately has exactly the
structural weaknesses
that marx described in his main work capital
the gaping scissors between
rich and poor have already arrived
others are emerging his
astute criticism of capitalism is
therefore more relevant than
ever no question marx still has a lot
to say to us
the book marx in 60 minutes explains
vividly and with great clarity using 70 central quotations
his materialistic
philosophy of history the basis superstructure
theory the criticism of religion and
the red-hot analyzes of surplus value accumulation impoverishment from capital
in the second part of the book entitled
what use is
the discovery of marx today
his findings a  applied to the current
current situation